Let's continue with this extension of the t test. Now that we have gone a
little in depth in the numerator, now let's focus on the denominator. Just like
we analyzed the variability of the sample or samples, which we used in creating
the standard error, we need to consider the variability of each individual
sample when we are comparing three or more. Let's ease our way into this idea,
starting with reflecting back on how the variability of individual samples
impacts the difference in means. In both of these situations, these two samples
have the same means and therefore, they have the same distance between means.
Nonetheless in only one of these situations are the means significantly
different from each other. Which one?